I Steve Robinson being the acting
returning officer at the election held
on Thursday the 7th of May 2015
do you hereby give notice that the
number of votes cast for each candidate
at the election is as follows Ingram
Stephen Leslie you Kip Independence
Party 4148 Matheson Christian
John Patrick known as Chris Matheson
Labour Party 22,000 118
mostly Steven James the Conservative
Party 20 2025
Thompson Robert James known as Bob
Thompson Liberal Democrats 2870
the number of ballot papers rejected
we're as follows voting for more
candidates than the voter was entitled
to 65 writing or mark by which the voter
could be identified 3 being unmarked or
wholly void for uncertainty 160 total
rejected votes 228 and therefore I
hereby declare that Christian John
Patrick Matheson is elected as the MP
for the city of Chester
returning officer ladies and gentlemen
it's been a long and testing night and I
don't want to delay you any longer than
is necessary and in doing so I thank you
and your staff returning officer for the
work you've done throughout the heat
this evening
and throughout the day and in preparing
for these elections and I thank Cheshire
Constabulary for their time-honored role
in protecting our democratic procedures
I'd like to thank my agent and my
organizer and my campaign team have
worked tirelessly over many months to
achieve this very narrow victory and if
I may as well I just say things about a
couple of the other candidates bob has
been my counselor in Hull he's not
standing again but he's a thoroughly
decent man I hope Bob that you will
continue to play a role within pool over
many years to come and for Stephen
Mosley who has served as the Member of
Parliament for Chester for five years
that deserves our gratitude and it
deserves our respect Steve I don't know
you well enough but I do know that you
absolutely dedicated to the area that
you live and I congratulate you on the
campaign and it's my view that whatever
happened nationally this has been a
campaign that locally has been convert
conducted with all through all by all
candidates in a manner that I believe
was positive and was on the issues and
not on personalities and was a credit to
all parties that took it took part and I
thank you all for that
I am grateful to the people of the city
of Chester for this huge honor I
represent all the people of the city of
Chester I will do so to the very best of
my ability and I will bear this honor
that you have given me with pride with
dignity with grace and with
determination to get the very best for
this constituency in this city I thank
you all thank you